I've pretended to break up with my  girlfriend for April Fool's and she told  me that she's been cheating on me anyway  I played a prank on a guy like to try to  get him to notice me but he filed the  police report instead I tried to prank  my friend by breaking off a piece of his  soda can tab but it went wrong and  exploded in my face I once tried to  freak out a guy by pretending to be  psychic it completely backfired and he  was really into it my ex tried to prank  me last night it ended with me telling  him I still love him now he won't answer  me back FML I tried to prank my brother  by pouring oil in the shower but I  completely forgot about it and I ended  up falling instead I wanted to play a  prank on my dad so I told him I had a  boyfriend he just laughed at me on April  Fool's Day I told everybody I broke my  ankle a few hours later I actually broke  it  hashtag Karma I pranked my boyfriend and  just thinking I'm pregnant  he left me  you  Oh